[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i was in a threesome one time in indiana
really yeah how was that
uh
it wasn't that great one girl pretty
cool her friend not cool
not very attractive you know not that
that matters but it also matters
and she kind of looked like remember
back in like vaudeville the vaudeville
weight lifters like those people who
wear the one strap and the thing and it
said a thousand kilograms on it you know
she looked like that like that old
school bodybuilder you know well she was
on the side of the bed doing [ __ ]
like
i don't know what she was doing burpees
or something while me and the one girl
having sex and they didn't even really
know each other that good so they were
also trying to get to know each other it
was [ __ ] awkward my friend had a
scale
and uh one of those old school scales
where you can measure somebody's height
he brought a girl home he's a big guy
played football
and she was thick oh yeah thick thick
and i respect a man who's not afraid if
someone was thick he put her on that
scale and he called me up next day and
he said
she came in at 5'3 184
and
and she looked up at me and i looked at
her and i said those numbers are not
good
you know i was talking to uh malik who
grew up boxing on larry moloch no molok
b
oh
oh yes and larry molly he keeps changing
his name dude it's mallet you know what
i'm saying that's the weirdest thing
sometimes you meet a black guy who
doesn't know how to pronounce it
i call him malek i don't know i like i
like the soft a i like and look honestly
seasonally i will change up how i do the
vowels in his name i will also call him
a lot malacca you know
if it's an egyptian holiday i'll [ __ ]
go full my lock on them my luck somebody
said you that you had four shoulder
blades is that true no it's not true it
just looks that way because i got i got
muscle on top of muscle i'm the first
comedian to develop muscle on top of
muscle you understand that's why the
doctor goes i got nothing to say oh yeah
he wrote on my chart immortal
i don't know if that's good i don't know
if that's good but he looked at my blood
panel and goes well guess you're never
going to die oh you're that hemoglobin
bad boy that's what it is
that's what it is that's why you could
sell my plasma on the black market for
as much as rhino horn goes for you know
what i'm saying jesus christ man people
are getting into that hell yeah i could
cut a diamond with my dick right now
damn dude yeah and we can do that yeah i
stretch up and i stretch oh that's crazy
yeah and i come over and sit on my lap
no what all right whatever this guy's a
[ __ ] baby this guy [ __ ] obviously
i hope this is
i do think uh intermittent fasting is a
really good idea wow and i think eating
simply and not overloading your body you
can feel it dude i've done i haven't
done intermittent fasting but i've had
mittens on before and it's so hard to
[ __ ] eat with men and that's the same
goddamn thing yeah how are you supposed
to butter your toast with mittens
it's impossible and then you're spitting
out whoop
damn it the thing is delaware could be
just taken over by maryland and you
would never notice
so i don't know if i'm even i think
delaware delaware's more of a province
of maryland yeah they call it the honky
puerto rico dude
delaware's barely silverware delaware
it's not even really named after much i
feel like we got it we got we got
somebody live on the scene
maryland would easily win the state
award bro we got michael phelps most
athletic guy in the world we always play
lewis he murdered someone once and got
away with it bro he'll do it again
we also have the white house
is in maryland
trump will nuke every single state that
tries to [ __ ] with us we literally
cannot lose period hey you're hey hey
you [ __ ] dummy hey michael is not the
most athletic person in the world and
and [ __ ]
how dare you say the white house is in
maryland you non-american get that isis
plant
off that screen don't ever bring that
guy up again well this is his buddy here
this is
don't ever
how the [ __ ] do you do a video lying
there like looking all cuddly and cozy
bro this is you when you were young we
got this out of a time capsule in high
school
delaware
i feel like delaware would just kind of
hide hiding in the corner somewhere like
under a table and then when
when the coast is clear they pop out and
do everyone [ __ ] he makes a point is
that he's right
where's that guy
why is his right hand all curled up on
his chest like a little cute polio man
if they got polio in delaware dude he's
holding the hanky or his little silk
that little piece of silk cloth his mom
gave him oh the guy was only this big
he's about that big yeah i was doing
these i never liked lifting weights i
just like whatever but i'm there and i'm
doing i'm doing those are unique too
those are those kind of like i'm a
kangaroo look at me you know that's for
your triceps i never could do i hated
working out where i was just doing curls
i was like i can't do it i want to do
something with like where i'm i feel
like i'm i'm becoming more athletic not
not not looking like a bodybuilder right
so i'm doing this stupid bodybuilding
thing and a guy gets behind me
he gets behind me he goes doing it wrong
a white guy yep
you're doing it wrong what's up and he
goes get your butt in there and he kicks
my knees
and he grabs my elbows and i'm like
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
here man so we just went with it we
dated for like three years i know and
then i was like i'm straight and i ran
out i was like i can't do this anymore
but you get confused
the answer to that question is you're
gonna sometimes you can get like what
the [ __ ] and you're living with each
other you have two small dogs you have a
vegetable garden
i'm not gay but it can take a while it
can take a while because it's
comfortable they can they it can get
comfortable when you're shacked up with
them they lull you in with the wind
chime you go to their house and there's
wind chimes and some of the wind chimes
it's other young men screaming for help
when the wind hits the pipe
[Music]
i've been attracted to um there's a guy
yesterday out of here
that's crazy from like where you get
that wind chime dude and why does each
chime have a person's name written on
you have somebody somewhere in this
house is there somebody under the
floorboards
i went to summer camp up in lake
winnipesaukee oh it sounds like that
that level is so clean you could drink
out of it again another progressive
state yeah another state that's so clean
it's ridiculous with your clean ass
lakes i grew up next to that
tuberculosis sipper that you funked a
river baby that's what i'm talking about
by the way the people agree 64 oh yeah
when you grow up you can you jump in
that water you can catch chlamydia oh
dude my buddy jumped in bro he got out
he was four years older
i believe it dude four years [ __ ]
older you had an std and you got eye
infections for the rest of your life oh
yeah how's your eye better right uh it's
okay dude but can you get pink out from
your own butt or not probably hmm i
gotta look that up we'll look it up
after this you can't be digging around
you're in your butt now i wasn't right i
wasn't there's a documentary on netflix
called crack
and remember crack babies they actually
have a crack baby okay i know a guy that
was all the time [ __ ] that was all
[ __ ] there were no crack babies
crack crack babies weren't born that way
most of the time it was a woman a woman
who was
doing drinking
marijuana but it wasn't that crack
itself was creating a whole generation
of kids who are addicted to cocaine
that's not oh yeah i never heard that i
just heard like if you had a real skinny
baby and he had jewelry on
but
yeah and i went to school in uh
charleston south carolina for a semester
and um i hitchhiked up there actually
from a boating regatta down in biloxi
mississippi and slept on a man's couch
for a while i almost got arrested
petting a cat on some lady's porch that
i didn't know yeah and don't do that
dude that's when you're at that [ __ ]
moment where you're like who am i you
know you're standing outside of a
sleeping woman's window pet and a cat
dude that's a problem that's when you've
thankfully put the cat down i [ __ ]
left she thought you were a peeping tom
oh well after that there's not much left
to do except crime that's true man
that's true i didn't know the cat now
you shouldn't have had your pants down
around your eyes
that's where she probably felt a little
now i wore two belts when i went over
there just so i'd have to think twice
before i did anything i understand real
quick if you love comedy you want to
support the art form we're featuring a
new up and coming comedian on our
instagram every day go check it out link
in bio uh follow us on there we'll send
you some free stickers bye so you got a
shitload of samoans and tongans maybe
the toughest people ever the dark parts
baby enjoy that [ __ ] enjoy fighting
those guys
enjoy fighting an army of men and women
because tongan women are stronger than
the average white european man yeah
that's a fact they'll beat the [ __ ] out
of you dude i saw a tongan guy get hit
by a spear bro and he giggled a little i
said it tickled tongans are not to be
[ __ ] with they walk around all of them
are
are way over 220 pounds they can sleep
standing up they're just crazy thick
that's insane bro sometimes at the
airport if their flight gets delayed
you'll see 60 or 70 of them sleeping in
a group
just standing yeah it's absolutely crazy
i mean you got to be quiet when you go
by them obviously how much how many
years did you put in including your
childhood that made you the comic that
you are oh yeah if you include childhood
dude a decent amount of years dude bed
wet until 30.
well if you include the [ __ ] night
shift i change my own sheets that's why
you wear those diapers that's awesome
sexy bro well i remember at one point i
would take a [ __ ] like uh towel or
sheet or something and wrap it around
like this big diaper and stuff as many
t-shirts out of there so when i pissed
again it would just absorb and i could
still just stay asleep how long have you
left the bed for oh he's no joke 30
years old is that right yeah man i just
was a just a traumatic sleeper yeah bro
i was just fighting [ __ ] dragons
people like you're gonna piss like yeah
i'm gonna [ __ ] piss now i'm [ __ ]
battling a [ __ ] orca with long arms
[ __ ]
if comics are so special and unique it's
so interesting like comics like what
what what was the dark arts dude i
remember i used to wake up in the middle
of the night because i remember hearing
that animals could get you at night
animals could get could get other
animals if if they hadn't urinated in an
area and i would piss around my bed in a
circle from my bed
to keep the [ __ ] animals away god
damn right and it works man yeah and
there's nobody checking in with me to
make sure everything's okay
nobody coming in my room and noticing
that there's just soggy spots in the
[ __ ] floor golden ring it's a golden
ring keep snakes away yeah dude coaches
black widow
bro yeah man god yeah what a [ __ ] bad
vampires i think piss keeps the vampires
away if you're a righteous man if you're
a righteous man you piss righteous
even vampires go this piss smells good
now there are more alligators in
mississippi but that just means
more of your guys are getting going down
yeah you're trying to sneak around bam
snap plus you got malaria when the whole
grid breaks down oh yeah you know
there's more water in mississippi so
everybody's got malaria you got malaria
jackson over there too dude and i think
i went to middle school with her hey
come on yeah he's gonna be here today
is he delia's yeah he looks up to me
there would be no crystal leo without me
he's open for me
and that is a fact dude and some people
have said that now there's a lot of
stuff out there you know
that um you know different comedians got
their vibes from different people you
know dice says that sebastian took his
style um
uh delia took he he
i gave him his essence what what well
the bravado i can see from the neck up
it's you everything about me he i was
his biggest influence and again
den and all that stuff go back just hey
just go back in the dinner all i ask is
go back to my early stuff yeah 10-minute
podcast before that all right fighting a
kid
all the way back go all the way back
please but this is happening before
he's my pup yeah i let him out of the
nest
and i'm glad he's flying i could shoot
him down anytime i want yeah but just
understand
i'm his biggest influence
at the end of the day i'm his [ __ ]
dad yeah
i'm his daddy oh yeah yeah oh yeah you
stand me oh i see it when i think of him
i think of him like soaring in the sky
right yeah but then i think of a man if
you look in the distance of that vision
yeah there's a man on a mountaintop and
he has that thing on his arm with a
piece of [ __ ] meat in the thing see
and you understand that and what you
also don't see is a is a very thin
piece
of fishing wire
that's attached to his ankle jesus
christ so anytime i want to yank him out
the sky
when he's soaring oh that's not a
problem for me when he's out there with
his [ __ ] guy a little linocie that
guy that [ __ ] bootleg italian no he's
not even italian he's not italian he's a
fraud oh dude it's so and that guy's
that guy's [ __ ]
i don't know he was adopted bro
and then returned
he was adopted and returned really yeah
so i'm not saying anything but a lot of
people were just adopting adopted and
returned yeah
they got a bum kid i mean i'm not saying
anything well you kind of are but i went
to french schools in lebanon when i was
a kid
and uh war-torn lebanon huh that's right
i was in the war there for for about
seven months we were evacuated to greece
and then uh i will be i've already
[ __ ] fell apart
not to say that with you right here but
no but i was doing some cia work i was i
was organizing coos oh yeah yeah dude
brendan's still coos sometimes that guy
is [ __ ] the worst vocabulary i've
ever heard
he's the only one
him in boston will talk but boston will
lead the conversation it's unbelievable
boss i haven't seen i've met boston you
haven't no fine as [ __ ] bro hey take it
easy just stay cute don't say fine bro
you're talking about a baby bro but this
baby
is about that lifestyle no no no i don't
know this baby comfortable with this
this baby's been at pool parties dude
i'm not you no the baby's big though
baby's got a head on him the baby's got
a freaking woo he's gonna be his biggest
daddy oh that baby is fine
hey hey hey no that baby's cute that
cute yeah baby
i don't like the way you're not are you
dragging out your words bro sorry
don't say cute with like four u's and
you can't do that bro and you're wiping
your mouth right now
i'm not comfortable
dude they call me the [ __ ] the flying
ass yep
i remember i remember that [ __ ] cheek
me hit in the air
god boy pink eye was my [ __ ] defense
that's what i'd give people i watch his
ass he doesn't wipe
[ __ ] on my eyes
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]